[Music]
yeah so that's exactly the point of the
stock so I'll be I'll be addressing sort
of a system they were they're currently
building a Forbes that incentivizes
members of that assigns team or other
members of Forbes if you're a software
developer you're more than welcome to
join to try out their ideas against a
specific business indicators and it does
that you succeed and it's a relevant
matter then we keep iterating over these
ideas if they fail they just go to a
very nice graveyard so here's what I'm
going to cover today so I'm going to
talk a little bit about the motivation
and why'd we decide to work with bots
and the problem area that they're trying
to solve how we collect analyze and make
recommendations for the cycle data
science of social media data and the
problem that we're trying to solve
specifically which is the problem of
publication optimization and this is
where the bot initiative comes along and
finally some conclusions and opening to
questions so I work at Forbes Forbes a
very large we now we're a hundred years
old and they're happy to celebrate and
phurba serves as a magazine and we're
very well known for that printed
publication now we also have a very
large website that publishes articles in
a number of different topics it's
largely caters to the business industry
but we published articles in all sorts
of things from celebrities to videogames
to technology etc now different than
other other other my colleagues
inferences BuzzFeed and a lot of war
traffic comes from search engines so
people search things on Google and
Google Google's mysterious sauce suggest
them to come to Forbes so there's a
number of there's a number of things
that generate that but one of the things
is the brand that we have or the history
and a lot of work that we've done in the
past to optimize each one of our
articles so that the rank very well on
on search engines so what this means is
that however today there's a lot of
people to consume their news using
social media right so but we
think is that we want more and more
people to read our articles but we think
that for us specifically given that were
already recruited well in in search
engines the opportunity is in social
media so we really need to tap into
social media and be much better at it to
drive traffic from social media
now given that that traffic is important
you know I don't have to convince you
about that understanding the phenomena
that generates our traffic it's not a
trivial problem and if you ever worked
with this there's a lot of things that
you start to understand about it but
things change quite quickly and there
isn't a single solution that works and I
think the key takeaway is that data
science teams become relevant be exactly
because this phenomenon is hard to
understand so I want to challenge your
intuition here is that scientists and I
want you to tell me among these four
articles which one generated a the
largest amount of social media traffic
in absolute numbers so on the top
left-hand we have an article about the
Eclipse
number two is an article about Apple
number three is an article about
celebrities and number four is an
article about business schools so if you
if you will humor me which one thinks is
one oh there you go
excellent good choice two Apple three
celebrities well done and for business
schools yeah I suppose now I didn't give
you a lot of properties imagine it is
just a headline and that's fine I think
this is the point of the exercise but I
think the reason why I've chosen just
for articles is that I think your
intuition is largely right celebrities
and Apple these things do perform quite
well but did it get it wrong here the
reason and there's a lot of reasons why
I mean just by pointing this out in
hindsight your intuition will also tell
you things oh maybe this is a list so
Liz
scary some sort of you know attraction
or this is about a phenomena that
happens very rarely so people maybe have
more pay more attention to a phenomena
or maybe this is advice so there's a
prescriptive aspect to it so people want
to be seen when they share articles as
being smart as telling you something and
Leslie this is written by astrophysicist
essence ego so he he was a very prolific
writer at Forbes and writes a lot about
astrophysics and generally very dry
physics topics lately over the last
three weeks has been published he
probably published about 50 articles
about gravitational waves so you know if
you're interested a topic he certainly
gets read now what's interesting about
this is that his articles never really
got a lot of page views I mean very
rarely unless you're interested in
gravitational waves and gravitational
waves being written at forbes.com
you know really there's a lot of people
who come for that content so a lot of
his traffic come from search engines but
in this article millions of pages were
generated by by people sharing things
much more than the search engine and
this this you know what I want to the
point I'm trying to make here is the
phenomena sometimes it's very difficult
to understand and to predict and act
upon now with that said we spent a lot
of time and a lot of resources to
collect and analyze social media data
and issue recommendations this is a
tradition of data science team structure
we collect better data we all know that
we analyze that data and great to see
that and we tell people what to do so
I'll tell you a little bit about this
initiatives but but this is not the main
point so I may I may ever look some
details and we can we can describe the
but in our question answer so here this
is a idea that we copied from BuzzFeed
you guys to created it very great idea
and the the point here is that somebody
comes to a website they read an article
we add a we append a hash code to that
article so Unicode then they take that
URL they share it somebody else clicks
on that share code and then a new share
codes
that second person and now you have a
parent children relationship so think of
it as the read shared click we like to
compute statistics out of this three
cycle two steps of things reach share
click and we think that this kind of
it's an interesting organic statistics
how people are really sharing these
articles and not kind of being simply
let's say the result of an algorithm of
certain social media platforms you know
to explain it a little bit more detail
you know hash aid is added to when
someone reads an article an article page
has shaken is shared on any given
Channel email or most likely social
media and a hash be is added whenever a
click is made on that article so person
be most likely kicks in that article and
a hash piece added so with that parent
and children relationship between hash a
and hash P we we created a number of
tools and this is just one of them that
helps us oops explore the dynamics of
that graph I don't want to go into too
much detail into into this tool so don't
look at the at the buttons etc but what
I'm showing you here is the graph that
was generated using a sample from that
article the five things that you must
not do during totality and this is
really interesting you can computer a
lot of properties from the graph and in
this particular case very interesting
and number of pageviews that come from
the graph this is the business the
caterer trying to maximize and we're you
know we're spending a lot of resources
in this kind of analytical tools now we
finished that that cycle by issuing some
recommendations and I've seen you've
seen this before we tell people things
like we tell the newsroom that you know
if you write list is better than not our
brain is very good at this if you if you
as hyperboles as fantastic trigrams work
really well from an early presentation
you won't believe you know this things
do work really well
now this all addressed the the concept
of content optimization and this is
something that we constantly work on but
I want to I want you to you know pivot
here in this presentation and in
challenges that I want to I want to make
a provocation here so the point here is
I think the traditional data science
cycle inside corporations like like
Forbes is that your insights lead to
action and you know that action is
generally not thinking about science
scene sticking with some other people
would you inform that action you tell
people what to do and you try to
substantiate it with some technique the
problem with this is that the the
business indicator you're trying to
change here is indirectly related to
your work it's most likely related to
how people implement those
recommendations now what we're what we
are really trying to do at at at Forbes
you know in my team is we're trying to
be directly responsible for business
Decatur's that have direct impact upon
so we're trying to move from inside to
product and that product is measured by
tangible business indicators now when we
were working on this problem of you know
how can I bring in more social media
traffic we working with with our social
media team when are trying to understand
with them what you know one of the main
problem areas but what can we do to
bring more social media traffic and you
know there's a lot of things that one
could one can work on but they start to
tell us really really obvious things
such as all of our social media team is
based in New York City and we're a
global website so whenever people are
waking up in India there's just nobody
you know the stream is now being fed
with sports content so that's an obvious
thing you know maybe you can publish
things at at our easy solution is just
to schedule things to that hour but they
search you mention a lot of a lot of
basic properties of the social media
world that they they want to address and
based on that idea we we search you come
up with oh you know instead of doing
content optimization sort of optimize
properties of our content we can search
you optimize for publication and then we
start to work with our social media team
to be a drag
responsible for for that business
indicator which is to bring more social
media traffic let me put this in a
little bit more tangible terms we
created this thing called the four spot
initiative and the first one initiative
inside a science team means that we want
to productize models in a way that the
that involves the creation of a lot of
really small engines so we want to try a
lot of different ideas and the models
which become independent small agents
that can do things to alter that
specific business indicator which is
bring social media traffic and each bot
is responsible is evaluated individually
for that for altering that is indicator
but else is the system you know the
collection of boss moves that indicator
directly the exclusive excuse
initiatives for now a focuses
exclusively exclusively on optimizing
publication in social media channels you
know and for the sake of of putting in
context you Autobots this does not have
a conversational interface some of them
have a resemblance of it but they don't
talk to people mostly there are small
software products that there are the
they are the embodiment of a model and
and the product eyes they give an output
to them oh so this is there are three
principles in this initiative and I
think this is a key principle is that I
want you guys to take away and I think
you know these are things that we we
focus a lot of time on one is that many
are is married unless his much better to
have many BOTS
that's for many different ideas and
fewer BOTS that have a lot of features
it's it's much better to have a lean
extremely simple bot
than to have about that is there's bloat
uncomplicated from a software and from a
massive perspective and finally all BOTS
needs to be measurable against very
clearly defined business indicators when
I say many mods I mean many and here
these are this is list BOTS
I don't really intend you to read all
the text but I think you to appreciate
the scope of the effort in which some of
them are implemented some of them boogie
in points between now and the end of the
year and the Explorer both simple and
complex ideas a simple idea can be let
me publish an article in the Eastern
time zone which is where we have a lot
of readers see how the article performs
in the first two hours a value project
that time series in the next three hours
and then use the best performing
articles in other times here in other
time zones such as the Western time zone
or in other worldly time zones like in
Europe or in India also for instance we
can have certain specific buds that
interact with other channels
distribution like I can have a bot that
calculates the price of advertising and
Facebook versus the price of the amount
of money that we get from ads in a
website and I can I can calculate that
Delta estimate how much that's going to
last into the future and by Facebook
advertising that and have that Bo try
that or I can have a release button and
this is an idea that I really like
Twitter is very toxic sometimes so if we
publish something for instance on
Twitter and that has a lot of traction
let's say we post something about a
basketball player or another celebrity
or whatever and then somebody replies to
that with some toxic or non toxin
response we can have a bot the response
to that with natural language and
responds with a related article which we
which we have an algorithm system in
what articles are related but now we
create YouTube channels for entry in our
website on the same post instead of just
one so it's a way of addressing
engagement without really addressing it
but you know by creating a chance of
entry and but the core idea here is that
many you know think think of this
building blocks you know the one-pot may
excel on an idea and may do really well
but then the function you're trying to
optimize may yield only so much more can
only can use only so much more traffic
in relation to that optimization
function what
can do is to experiment a different idea
at the same time and see how much more
that yields you and as a system that
performs great and also as a site as a
site consequence of this approach is
that you can start hedging your bets and
by that I mean for instance you can
create a bot that focuses a lot of
virality on how people share things
among each other now it so happens that
certain parts of the year people are not
sharing things that much so you can
focus if that bot starts failing in
other parts of the year let's say in
according which things are not so
shareable Autobots can fill in that gap
so your overall system metrics continue
to be great but that but it's not not
performing that well and that's great
because you know you can decide to kill
that bot or optimize that function or
rates rate or just retire it and you
know bring it again whenever it's useful
so the second the second concept here is
isn't creating simple BOTS so bus have
to be very simple to create and by that
I mean the user experience of Korean
BOTS for the developer has to be
extremely simple for the data scientist
that creates an insight you know has to
be very simple and by that intentional
terms I mean it must take a week between
inside and production so with that what
I what I mean by that is that if you're
as there are science affords you cannot
put an insight and you realized that
people who speak this kind of language
on Twitter are more keen to share
articles of this hour today we want you
to use that insight and the result of
that train model cue to generate more
traffic social media to create a bot in
one week weird
so we don't want you to worry about
anything else in one week of course the
investigation may take a lot of time but
in one week after you have that insight
you have to be able to productize that
bot and how we do this there are two
major areas of work one is operation
abstraction and here we're thinking
about a lot of internal api's that are
useful for many areas of the business
not just BOTS and these are for instance
recommendation API is entity extraction
at the eyes you know
trigrams and by Graham's analysis utter
contempt sensation algorithms and so
forth
statistics API and so forth and the
second area is the publication of
measurement either the publication of
measurement operations on social media
is this areas abstracted into a large
piece of codes so basically if everybody
needs to post on social media
let's abstract that piece of code into
its individual larger software and then
the model becomes just just models just
nimble models that can be executed in
your own Python notebook if you if you
feel so inclined and that's the that's
the piece of work that we are calling
bad stream and the second area which is
one of my favorite areas and I'm always
thinking about this when I'm developing
software is I love I love the problem of
developing experience you know if you've
ever used scikit-learn it's very you
know it's very rewarding to fit a model
and psyche learning to predict and the
the mental model that you creates you
use that software is very very simple in
opposition for instance if you're using
tensor flow that you have to learn how
to think about in the in terms of flow
way and those are different problems in
different solutions but the idea here is
that I love I love developing software
thinking about how other developers who
use it and particularly will use it to
create some sort of useful product out
of it so here we're thinking about
creating series of Python packages and
we'll show you a little bit of how this
works so that people can create that
that bought really quickly and put into
production really quickly so in turn API
is there are all sorts of things like
statistics and content and
recommendation api's and others and they
they do things for instance if you go to
a website you may see a reading list on
the left hand side or at a time that you
come to the website that release may
change or different recommendations may
change based on your geography or other
other properties when you visit the
website so this is one one of the
implementations or you may see some
numbers on each article page and those
numbers also come from different
statistics api's but for instance some
of this API as were created based on
needs that bots had
and instead of us implementing that code
inside about we decided is to create an
API that is useful for the business in
this case is useful for the article
pages to render elements on the page but
are also used by the bots so BOTS you
know hopefully there'll be almost
stateless in a sense so bad stream is
where the largest piece of software here
is and bot stream you know think of it
as sir you're a be testing engine for
BOTS what it does it it's it's a single
piece of software it controls all the
publication process to all social media
platforms out there it also collects
relevant statistics for each one of the
bots so everything that BOTS schedule
for publication it will collect a lot of
statistics about and it uses that same
share code that we saw at the beginning
so each BOTS has a unique series of
circles and those shortcuts are used to
understand exactly how the graph is
built from that from each one of their
attempts to publish in social media all
this is done automatically and in a
little bit I'll show you some of the
things we do but and it finally provides
interfaces so that people can track this
both in on the browser and on slack you
know this is generally how it looks
there isn't a lot of detail here but the
key concept here is the bots should be
very simple applications in terms of
software requirements they're as they
can be as small as 10 lines of code in
Python they can be written I pass a
notebook or they can be really no GS if
you're so inclined but you know
generally would like things to be
written in Python they can be deployed
locally on your own machine or they can
be deployed in one of our ec2 instances
most likely they come in the form of
docker containers so they can be
deployed across a number of hosts but
they are very nimble applications
hopefully stateless you know they're
like lamb but lambda functions you know
think of I'm a Amazon Amazon's a lambda
infrastructure now the point is that
they use if they need a lot of a lot of
data that comes elsewhere then that
hopefully has been already implemented
into some sort of abyss
API that is useful for there are the
errors of the business so the bots can
just square that API get the data that
they need make the inferences and then
take an action upon it and that action
being scheduling your post it's a
request but stream for that possibly
that article to be pushed into a certain
social media channel or in all social
media channels bot stream is where also
contains it contains a queue a basic
queue of publications and contains a
scheduler that tries to publish things
that the hours that have been requested
to be published but it also includes a
lot of business logic not to make
mistakes if so happens that 10 different
BOTS requires you to publish the same
article 10 different times but stream
itself will include logic to not make
such mistakes so it's kind of a
gatekeeper for the BOTS who do not know
of each other to this to avoid the boss
from making mistakes the core element
here also and the bots is that BOTS also
independent from each other did not
require that from each other to take
actions they do not even know of the
present of each other but what they can
do is a liquidity cook they can consume
streams of other BOTS
so if I am a bot that focuses on a
certain sharing pattern I can subscribe
via boss stream to a stream of all the
actions that are not about staking so
that I can use that to inform one of my
actions so basically BOTS can consume
data from choo-choo large to large pools
of data one is their intern api's or
stern api's and another one is the
stream small robots and that combination
can yield some interesting some
interesting results yeah so that's
that's most that's if you join a lot of
science team and if you're part about
the bad initiative most likely you're
you've just focused here and there's a
lot of other people working on the other
part of the system but most likely
you're only focused on this part so we
have a nice little slack interface you
can ask things to it and slack and we
have you know very nimble you either you
can you know check things and see when
they're going to be published and check
the statistics of each bot and it's
nothing there is remarkable now this is
this is what about a very simple but
will look like and here by my model I'm
taking deliberate of you know the model
meaning a random choice between an array
of previously previously generated
articles but here's the concept that
we're trying to push forth when we when
we think about improving the developer
experience if you want to create a bot
you can just start by well let me pour
the bot stream library let me import the
Forbes library so I can I can have X
have access to our internal api's let me
get a list of articles that are popular
let me randomly choose one of them and
let me schedule the article for
publication that's it
and I think you know this developer
experience allows you to focus a lot
more on this part of your code on
creating your model we want to train a
deep neural core to understand how
certain sentences and articles are
related to each other and understand if
one article is going viral maybe you can
use that relationship to post a
different one but the whole point here
is that you have to spend a lot of time
here on creating the model and coming
out with that array of articles that you
want to publish in and when you want to
publish them and finally just just ask
for the schedule to do it itself just
ask bot stream to do it itself finally
you can evaluate the results of that bot
you know you can collect statistics of
that bot and bot stream will give you a
lot of the statistics so you can you can
analyze yourself how how are you doing
the third and final principle here is
that our BOTS need to be measurable and
again we're talking about clear business
indicators and for instance here think
about pageviews well the number of
people that pages are generated by an
individual bot and what or what are the
number of engagement statistics so you
know for instance number of likes or
Tara that are generated by an individual
bot the good thing about this is that
this to this is automatically collected
by BA stream and we've included some
some logic in bloodstream that every
time the robot requires for something to
be posted bustering would randomly
select the post as a control or a
trimming
and would automatically continuously
perform t-test on this the performance
of these publications and this cool
because you can see if that idea has
having an impact on on number of
pageviews for instance or if it's just
if it's just a function of a different
idea that you're not really capturing
quite yet and this is really cool
because as soon as in one week as soon
as you write that that first instance of
that model you push it out a number of
times and you start to collect and and
and see the difference between the
treatment and the control groups you can
already start your tuning that idea or
throw it away completely and try
something else you know it's it's a very
quick quick way of testing it so the the
cycle for you to select a lot of users
or understand a large dynamics become
much faster
and finally it's the same interface for
measuring all of the spots
so all these bots are measuring our
measure against the same category of
business indicators which means that if
one but if in absolute terms one bot
only generates so much maybe is even if
that idea is a brilliant idea
maybe it's much better to go with
something that is much simpler because
that other idea generates a much greater
much greater numbers so here's here's 10
of the talk and I want to open for a few
questions you know there's a few
provocations on that I brought up but I
think the conclusion so the impact your
business is there today are non-trivial
so we start with the problem of we want
to generate more social media traffic to
Forbes given that most of our traffic
comes from SEO statistics comes from
search engine we have a small number
traffic for the industry a small
relative traffic chronicity comes from
social media and we have in the last
three months we have managed to affect
this traffic in a non-trivial way so
today a non-trivial amount of pageviews
from social media are generated by
efforts of bots and that's good and
until the end of this year we will have
approximately
fifteen BOTS in operation depending on
how many dive is in London operation
trying different ideas and we hope that
thing together ultimate about 50% of our
social media our social media posting
and interactions and this means that the
humans that work on that area they can
focus on things that add a lot more
value to the business
for instance live events and social
media which generated a lot of a lot of
traffic but they're much more expensive
to do and the conclusion here that I
want to leave you as you know as when
you're creating new data science
initiatives in your in your respective
businesses is that in my opinion I think
it's really interesting to focus on on
creating a system that allows for very
quick experimentation in our case we're
tackling two areas operate we're
abstracting the operations that are very
repetitive for each one of the each one
of those models to actually take effect
and to we're improving the developer
experience the second point is
experiments are really useful to be
evaluated individually and also as part
of the system's are part of so if you're
trying to bring social media traffic
grifton together and see if together
they can drive that traffic up we'll
don't be too attached to an individual
way of doing things because if it fails
you can quickly try a different idea and
finally and to me one of the most
important points is that the developer
experience matters if you make it really
enjoyable to experiment with different
models and different concepts you'll
most likely find something that works
much faster than otherwise so this is
the other presentation and I wanted to
open up for questions I don't know how
much time left
oh good yes I wonder if you have in
questions of a happy Chancellor I mean I
ever looked a lot of details on the
software part of it or if you have any
questions about specific bots I'll be
happy to answer it yeah question
yeah I already has one so I wonder what
do you think is the biggest clear
advantage that bot has over having an
actual an analyst to round this kind of
analysis in databases and like is that
the budget replies like a you know a
regular analyst role no that's that's a
good question I think the analyst will
create an insight the bot is the
software implementation of that insight
so I think the the analyst will create
the model the model the model IDs to
issue a class but you classify something
to predict something about the future
and that and the bot will be the
software implementation of that model so
both things go together so bots need to
be created by analysts I don't think one
thing replaces the other although with
that question one of the things that
we've been thinking about is to create
BOTS that can create autobots and this
is a really cool idea that could work in
certain large areas of work for instance
given the we're a global website how
could we create a bot that is able to
study for instance how different topics
or different kinds of publications react
with different audiences around the
world and then based on the findings of
that instead of creating for instance a
very large narrow network to adapt to
each one of the airs the world creates a
small narrow network they just focus on
the area of the work let's say an India
bot that just focuses on posting things
relevant to India or China bought that
focusing staying relevant to China and
so forth so we that said yeah maybe in
that case it will give us more time so
you can enjoy our lies but otherwise
both things BOTS require analysts right
now
sorry there's a microphone hi my name is
Mike thank you for the talk so you do
some analysis on the titles of the
different posts do you do any analysis
on the content of the article in a way
to suggest to the editor that they
should be using shorter sentences longer
sentences different words that's a you
know there's a really great question
here I only you know focus on the body
initiative we have so the way that we
publish things that we have a CMS you
know articles you know generally writers
will write things in word for instance
and they will put it in the CMS and they
publish it now we do have a content
optimizer in or CMS that will give those
kinds of recommendations and they
largely would focus on you know the
length of the article or the number of
images that he has or if it contains you
know certain grammatical structures or
not etc now what we want to do next in
the next quarter is to have have people
write articles directly on the CMS and
have either as a writing an article has
sort of I think in a previous
presentation by Firefox that we're
talking about how to help students get
in loans
kind of have that human assist a human
with a with an AI system so as they're
writing an article have that that model
keep suggesting things for instance
you're writing an article about
deepmind's latest paper you know an AI
article that articles about how now you
don't need to use games to train a new
go model to perform better than humans
you can just teach it the roles and you
will train itself now as you're writing
the article one of one of ideas is that
as you're writing it what we can do is
that Oh instead of writing Google has
been working on open source software to
make this more available one of the
things that we can do is that we can
suggest that author to include well
maybe you want to include the link to
tensorflow
and include an entity there and by
adding that entity we estimate the
article to perform better than than
otherwise
yeah so it's long it's a long way the
effort to say we're thinking a lot about
that and right now we're a new iteration
of idea
is to make that process of collaborative
collaboration between human and survey I
as you know seamless as possible as
you're writing it keep suggesting you
things entities and different
grammatical structures or images and
it's all it's all measured against an
estimate how we think the articles gonna
perform yeah I want to ask about your
your kind of provocation where you're
going from insights to instead of
actions products yeah so this this idea
is it is a partially driven by the idea
that what an analyst finds an
interesting insight they kind of pass it
off to stakeholders sort of throwing it
over the fence and missing kind of the
follow-through of the implementation of
of the insight and if so if these bots
are intended to kind of replace
stakeholder actions do you see a kind of
decrease in the amount of communication
between the science team and the
stakeholders yeah that's a really good
question I think early yesterday we had
a presentation by a New York Times that
scientists it was a great presentation
about how to distribute newspapers and I
think you know one of the things that
stuck in me about the presentation was
that they came up with this model on how
to predict the optimal amount of
newspapers that had to be sent to each
place now when they when they said this
is a great model the business interest
said no this is awful
we want more papers to be sent because
we have this utter not yet measured
statistics that we care about so I think
to answer your question it depends on
what you I think you know it is a great
thing if you're able to affect
businesses Decatur's directly because
now you're way more responsible to
things and you have to answer certain
things if you're saying that you're
going to increase your social media
traffic that's not about recommendations
but it's about actually doing it you
know there's a software they written to
do it on the really bad side you're
absolutely right we're trying to create
this concept where you know about
ideation sessions of bought breeding
sessions you know the idea of bring
people into room and
specifically from the from a social
media team and say you know what are the
ideas that you have so that we can share
with you and partially we created this
lack interface and and the web
interfaces where people can track that
but I think you know as much as I want
to pay lip-service that yes I think the
consequence is the more you become a
software company the more you become a
product company the last become that
kind of a service company and the
unintended consequences that you know it
starts to cut into that into that way of
doing things
we're hoping to address it by including
people and and in design things together
but you know I think it is related to
that it's interesting it seems like
there could be a middle ground where if
the stakeholder is committed to the bot
as kind of the instantiation of their
idea or their insight and their there
could be that kind of connection that
that's maintained no in fact the bust we
work earlier today I think most were
created by the social media team we were
basically the implementers but most the
idea came from them but I still think
that you know because we're in the
trenches we're much closer to them to
the bots but I agree with you I think
that's the right middle ground yeah I
think that's the best thing we can do
right now I have two questions as the
first one you mentioned that evaluation
is sort of tied to business metrics and
that's very nice to do but often
business metrics are also proxy for
something else for example pageviews
might be a proxy for revenues somewhere
yeah so have you found some sort of
conflict in sort of evaluating models
based on business metrics rather than
something else that it
it's proxying fought and also is that
room for qualitative evaluation but oh
that's a very good point I'll answer the
latter one first yes
measuring for force brand is really
important measuring the brand is really
difficult
so editors know how to do that better
than we do so we we didn't have a lot of
back-and-forth to figure out what that
looks like and in energy avoid having
the bots make mistakes now
in terms of business metrics
I would really like to i really dislike
using page views to be honest I like
using dollars it is really difficult to
use dollars for a lot of reasons but
we're pushing to use dollars we're
really really pushing to use dollars
we're really pushing to the the ticker
that changes is a dollar ticker because
that is that is our business we want
articles ads for instance go back to the
CMS somebody's writing an article if
they add tensorflow and a link to the
thanks for a librarian github if the
dollar ticker now moves a couple
thousand dollars that's great and I
think that's a great motivator for
everybody to understand how to impact
the business so we're moving more and
more to dad there's a lot of challenges
if you work with programmatic
advertising you may have realized that
it's difficult to actually estimate how
but we're we're working on on using
dollars versus other metrics yeah but I
really would want to use dollars for
everything okay my second question was
going to be about good question so butts
don't really interact with each other
they consume streets from each other so
we do I mean there isn't really much to
measure there so we I want to say we
don't really know
[Music]